this is tamar hussein reading for
reviewer janae sitsis
pokemon snap has nothing to do with
catching or battling with pokemon
and humans aren't at the heart of its
story instead snap has always been about
the joy of discovery
and uncovering the secrets of the
pokemon world without really interfering
it's long lasting charm stemmed in part
from witnessing moments it felt like you
weren't supposed to see
20 years later that same charm and
mystique is present in new pokemon snap
on nintendo switch
the neo one will automatically follow a
set route
with even more courses and pokemon to
discover new pokemon snap is a brand new
adventure that's absolutely delightful
to embark on
incorporating newer generations of
pokemon and stunning environments that
feel truly alive
as in the first game new pokemon snap
opens with you a budding photographer
joining up with a pokemon professor to
snap some photos for his research
the mystery at the heart of the game is
quickly introduced professor mira is
investigating a strange illumina
phenomenon that's causing some pokemon
in the lentil region to glow
and you're here to catch in action and
discover its source
the story itself isn't particularly deep
and it feels somewhat half-baked
but having the narrative reasons for
continuing to explore each island does
help progression feel natural and well
paced
charming voice actor cutscenes with
professor mirra and the research team
help draw you in and add to the overall
presentation what you're really here for
though are the new courses which you
explore in a pod-like vehicle
known as the neo-one these take you
through all sorts of natural pokemon
environments
from thick jungles to vast deserts and
underwater caverns
though some of them are similar
thematically to courses that were
present
in the 1999 game such as the beach level
new pokemon snap also takes you to brand
new environments
these feature a mix of pokemon from all
eight generations existing in their
natural habitats
each environment is full of life with
something happening in nearly every
direction you look
the thrill of discovery is still at the
heart of its gameplay
whether you're photographing a pokemon
that bursts out in front of you
or zooming in to take a shot of one
that's hidden in the distance
the sense of wonder and constant
anticipation of what you'll see next in
new pokemon snap is exhilarating
like its predecessor new pokemon snap is
very much a game that revolves around
capturing special moments
and making those happen is the game's
core challenge though you initially
start out with just your
camera you soon receive items from
professor mira that allow you to get a
pokemon's attention and evoke reactions
from them
these tools are key to drawing pokemon
closer and triggering special reactions
or poses that will give you better
photos to show the professor
however a constant level of
experimentation is required as each
pokemon will react to your actions
differently
with a bit of planning you can also
trigger interactions between pokemon
like creating a path of fluff routes to
reunite a dealing with a source bug
or causing a fight to break out between
pincer and heracross
these memorable moments motivate you to
keep using your items on pokemon in new
ways
and that trial and error approach keeps
things fresh and interesting
nighttime courses are a dynamic addition
to the series in new pokemon snap
not every course has separate times of
the day for exploration but many do
which effectively expands the number of
pokemon and types of encounters you can
find
though each day and night course is on
the exact same track they feel
distinctly different
during the day the bustling jungle is
alive with activity and sounds of
pokemon cries
while at night it's quiet calm and
peaceful with sights of pokemon
slumbering as you travel by
nocturnal pokemon also come out to eat
and play during this time
these offer brand new encounters for you
to photograph while also giving you a
fuller experience of each pokemon
ecosystem by letting you see what
happens when the sun goes down
when you return from your excursion
professor mirror is waiting to score
your photos
each photo is scored on a scale of 1 to
4 stars
with criteria including a pokemon's pose
size the direction it's facing
and other pokemon in the photo and more
the long-term goal is of recording a
photo of every pokemon at each star
level
the criteria can get a bit murky as you
aim for photos with higher stars
the emphasis seems to be on behavior
more than anything else
so a photo where a pokemon further away
is performing that action might rank
better than a photo where the pokemon is
close up but not engaging in special
behavior
while it's enough to file away in your
photo decks to fill that star
requirement
it might not be a photo you feel
particularly proud of that feeling is
counted by the ability to save photos to
your personal album
which is particularly fulfilling after
each scoring session with professor
mirror
you're given the opportunity to go
through and save any of the photos
you've taken in your personal album
in this stage you can re-snap the photo
of a given moment
so if a pokemon is half out of the frame
you can reposition the crop so that the
entire pokemon is
in frame and visible other modern photo
editing features are available as well
letting you brighten or darken the image
add a filter adjust the focus
and add a caption this lets you build up
an album of photos that have your
personal touch on them
and it becomes a much more satisfying
reflection of your excursions and
discoveries
there's something especially satisfying
about crafting a personal album of
photos that's reflective of your own
style and tastes
your own mini pokey instagram if you
will and that's the core gameplay loop
just as it's always been
venture out take photos then come back
and have them scored by the professor
while repetitive new pokemon snap is
never boring
keeping its replayability high with
courses that change over time
the more you visit a particular course
the more likely you are to see new
pokemon appear and opportunities for a
new encounter
which keeps the experience fresh and
exciting throughout each course can be
leveled up three times with points that
you earn from photosnap there
which provides a driving reason for you
to keep revisiting the area and taking
higher quality photos
this keeps the sense of discovery alive
you may think you know a course down pat
and then you'll see a brand new pokemon
come out of nowhere to surprise you
a new feature known as requests assists
with this ongoing discovery in a major
way
requests are basically little hints the
research team gives you for discovering
new pokemon or behaviors on a given
course
these range from vague observations to
fairly specific directions that will
cause something
interesting to happen with a pokemon or
between a few of them
the requests aren't forced on you and
you're given very little direction at
all as you explore an environment say
for a scanning feature that can prompt
you to observe certain details or
discover a new
route through an area however it became
apparent that requests are incredibly
useful in the late game
as you focus on maxing out each course
and taking four star photos of every
pokemon
some of the encounters you can trigger
are highly specific and not something
you might discover on your own
so requests are a helpful tool in
ensuring everyone is able to experience
these moments for themselves
they also help provide clear goals for
subsequent visits to a course
which could otherwise become
frustratingly repetitive though requests
help you discover cool moments and snap
high star photos
sign posting isn't as adequate when it
comes to story progression
while you'll usually unlock what's
needed to progress in the story
naturally
as you experiment with items and perform
subsequent runs through a course
the game doesn't explicitly tell you
what's needed to proceed to the next
island there's at least one situation
where in order to discover a new route
you have to perform a specific action on
a pokemon near the beginning of a course
hints around this action are extremely
vague which can lead to general
confusion about what you have to do to
proceed
the existence of requests early on can
mislead as well
as you may assume they're required for
story progression when they're really
intended to help you fill your photo
decks so it's easier to get caught up in
doing requests thinking you will
eventually unlock a new route
when really the game is expecting you to
perform specific actions within a level
that will reveal the path forward
though it's generally appreciated that
the game doesn't hold your hand and
expects you to experiment and discover
things for yourself
tying vague requirements to story
progression can cause a frustrating
stall for those trying to move forward
fans climbed for a pokemon snap remake
for years and with new pokemon snap
we've gotten even more than we bargained
for
an incredible sequel that pulls from all
eight generations of pokemon released so
far
dynamic courses that can be explored
during both daytime and night time
and the ability to create an album of
edited personalized pokemon photos which
you can then print or post online
a fitting evolution of the game in the
social media era
though there's sometimes a disparity
between photos that might make it into
your photo decks and ones that you like
the most
the core motivation of catching a
pokemon doing something particularly
cool remains the driving force
and the satisfying draw of new pokemon
snap 20 years later
taking photos of pokemon in the wild
remains as fun and exhilarating as it
always was
and though it's been a long time coming
new pokemon snap was worth the wait
you